[Musique]
les premiers jours je pense que comme
beaucoup de gens on était soit sur
l'adrénaline
il ya des moments d'obscurité terrible
ya des moments de lumière
c'est un peu une montagne russe
d'émotions pour la phrase ça va bien
aller
ça fait longtemps que ça va pas bien
[Musique]
les conséquences sur la santé mentale de
la pandémie vont durer beaucoup plus
longtemps que la pandémie allemagne
ça fait des semaines que notre monde
complètement basculé presque deux mois
déjà qu'on apprivoise l'absurde et
l'insécurité
un état d'anxiété souvent je parle de m
mais en ce moment c'est plus comme une
ruche c'est un bourg de l'un à
l'intérieur dé costa carlos perez vit
seule à montréal
décorateur à son compte il est comme des
millions d'autres ou chômage force
[Musique]
hanks une nature son état s'est empiré
j'arrive pas à me concentrer j'ai fait
les cent pas la maison j'arrive pas à
m'asseoir élire lives leur d'apéro est
un petit peu plus tôt que l'habitude la
consommation connaît des soucis lorsque
ça aide
parce que le sommeil est perturbé il
s'est résigné au casse tête et/ou zapiro
virtuel un antidote à l'ennui ni par la
solitude c'est de pas avoir accès à mes
amis c'est de pas avoir accès à ma
famille c'est de ne pas avoir accès au
toucher de quelqu'un sais c'est dur
quand on est seul de porc de pour
toucher et de corps et ça rien de sexuel
nécessairement mais c'est celle de le
contact avec quelqu'un et c'est que
nature et ils continuent de consulter
son thérapeute à distance car il en a
encore les moyens ce qui est loin d'être
acquis pour tous ceux qui souffrent de
la pandémie à différents degrés
tout le monde n'est pas en détresse
psychologique mais cela dit je pense que
la détresse actuellement les
silencieuses comme présidente de l'ordre
des psychologues
christine groulx a mobilisé ses membres
qui sont prêts à aider on pourrait
organiser des écoutes téléphoniques
on pourrait organiser des entrevues de
soutien des entrevues d'éducation
psychologique juste de savoir c'est quoi
l'anxiété mais pour l'instant les
psychologues demeure une ressource sous
utilisés parmi les mesures d'urgence qui
ont été déployés par le gouvernement
le feu est tellement pris dans les
centres d'hébergement de soins de longue
durée
mais moi je crains beaucoup le feu qui
est en train de prendre silencieusement
un pic qui risque de faire un énorme feu
de paille de ne pas s'occuper de la
santé mentale c'est une erreur
on est rentré dans cette crise avec une
santé mentale déjà fragile
donc si c'est difficile ce soir on va
pas sortir indemne de sa infirmières
engagé nataliste acquis doucet a fait le
soudan 1 ch celles dignes trois semaines
chaque quart de travail amène son lot
d'horreurs qu'elles appréhendent dès
qu'elle y met les pieds je regarde les
gens du chip de jo c'est de la joie
juste larrieu puis le feront parce qu'on
est tout masquer avec une visière le
c'est de regarder accueillant dans
comment il y en a dix qui ont les yeux
pleins d'eau il y en au dessus qui on va
franchir le siphon l'air bien des fois
un joueur
la peur de la pm beaucoup de perdre mais
pas le temps de s'arrêter même pas pour
ventiler juste chanceux je suis
extrêmement bien entouré mon mari est un
homme extraordinaire qui qui m'attend en
tout les soirs piqué qui fait parler
pour que si j'apprécie avec lui que je
le fais je peux si on peut appeler ça un
traumatisme encore là mais c'est
définitivement
quelque chose qui vient gruger ton angle
surtout la nuit
les sunny est devenue coutumière il pas
seulement chez les travailleurs de la
santé se sentir une 6e puis vouloir
pédaler dans le beurre c'est c'est aussi
mal dormir c'est aussi avoir des sautes
d'humeur
c'est un gros bible frédéric loiseau
faisait dans la production d'événements
culturels dans un passé pas si lointain
[Applaudissements]
musique au spectacle du grand
rassemblement c'était sa passion
ils sont balle jaune la dengue monsieur
legault qui apparaît à la télévision qui
disent que vous faites est maintenant
illégale qu'ils ont on arrête tout s'est
passé comme je suis une claque banc face
chaque jour il se bat pour rester sain
d'esprit
difficile quand le bateau coule et
emporte tous les collègues et amis tout
les téléphones que j'ai avec tous mes
collègues entrepreneurs engagés commence
par un long ray rice a expliqué quel
point un malaise qui sont et qui est
énorme on s'appelle bien on rit puis on
rit comme on rit jean mauvais temps se
demande même pas comment ça va c'est un
long rires mal aisé de dire je sais que
ça va pas bien tu sais que ça va pas
bien
what's next et c'est ce qu'il sait de
pau savoir
c'est qu'à la fin et non seulement ces
cas-là fait mais ça va être quoi nos
côtés de tout ça dans une société où la
dépression et l'anxiété sont encore trop
souvent vue comme une faiblesse
il n'a jamais été aussi important d'en
parler je suis pas déprimé en ce moment
toujours le programme d'aidé aux
employés qui avaient cinq stations avec
de psychothérapie mais je pense que nous
falloir pas mal parce que ceux en
sortant de cette crise
si le gouvernement s'est vu obligé
d'improviser
de son propre aveu pour lutter contre un
ennemi visible
cette fois il est prévenu des effets
pervers parfois silencieux mais
potentiellement catastrophique qui
resteront bien au delà du déconfinement